what's the most frustrating rule in
chess well stalemate is one of the most
confusing and often frustrating rules in
the game of chess stalemate is when one
player's King is trapped but it is not
in check and that player has no other
pieces either on the board or off but
can move anywhere stalemate is a draw
and usually it happens by accident when
one player is completely dominating the
other player but instead of delivering
Checkmate they accidentally stalemate
the king stalemate almost always occurs
at the end of a game here's an example
white has many checkmates but let's say
the queen moves to this Square that's a
big mistake the White Queen does not
attack the black king from there but it
does block all of the squares the king
could move to Black has no other pieces
and so this position is stalemate we
could add some pawns here but they're
still blocked so this is still stalemate
so if you want to win deliver Checkmate
instead and if you're in trouble in an
end game see if you can trick your
opponent into stalemating you